um of course what we have seen on the
ground uh
actually since last spring
is that they are moving forces around
but that doesn't represent a real the
escalation
uh and we're also seeing that sometimes
they move into a position with
a combat to the troops and a lot of
heavy equipment
and then they take out some of or
perhaps even most of the troops but they
leave
the equipment behind and then they can
very quickly reinforce and move all the
people back all the troops back again if
needed so the movement of forces the
movement of
of russian capabilities doesn't
represent real
de-escalation
nato strongly believed that
all nations have the right to choose
their own path
and and the nato's door remains open
the enlargement of nato has been a great
success it helps to spread democracy
freedom and ensure peace and stability
across europe for four decades
so so far we have not seen any
de-escalation on the ground from the
russian side
over the last weeks and days we have
seen the opposite
a continued military buildup with more
troops more
battlegroups more high-end capabilities
artillery
air
defense missiles and a lot of support
elements
that makes it possible to for russia to
move into ukraine
for a full fled generation or a more
limited military incursion with
hardly any warning time at all
that picture's picture has not changed
so far
but we monitor we follow what they do
and and we believe there is some
ground for cautious optimism
based on the
signals uh and signs coming from moscow
that they're ready to
engage continue to engage in a
diplomatic effort and we are ready to
continue to engage in a diplomatic
effort i think what fundamentally what
we see
is that two authoritarian powers
russia and china are operating together
because they don't like a rules-based
international order they don't share our
values freedom democracy
and that's also the reason why they're
trying to deny sovereign democratic
nations the right to choose their own
future
they they want a world where big powers
can decide what smaller powers and
countries can can do
so this is this is about
fundamental principles whether
free independent countries can choose to
be part of
an alliance as nato
or they can choose to stay out we should
respect it anyway